another point we need to make before we
break derek carr took to social media
recently and created some speculation of
a trade to the bears his big brother
david carr says that derek carr is
simply trolling and i think that it's
even more than just trolling i think
derek carr is frustrated by all the talk
about being supplanted with the las
vegas raiders so he's trying to turn the
tables a little bit and try to generate
a narrative where he's going to be
supplanting someone else now i don't
know how much of an upgrade he is over
mitchell trubisky although bears fans
seem to think that anybody at this point
would be an upgrade over mitchell
trubisky but
derek carr i don't think at this point
is going to be the raiders quarterback
week one
uh because mike mayok has said it
multiple times over the course of the
last year they are constantly looking to
upgrade and last year they kicked tires
on kyler murray and dwayne haskins
before the draft this year there are too
many veterans out there i think the only
way that carr comes back is if they go
all in to get tom brady and all the
other guys get gobbled up and they don't
get tom brady they're going to have to
keep the bird in the hand for one more
year barring some development in the
draft but i think that that is the most
likely scenario that that derek carr
stays with the raiders
mike i always say this i've said it for
probably 20 years about john gruden
his favorite quarterback is the one he
doesn't have
and so i don't necessarily think john
gruden wouldn't play
2020 with derek carr but every year
every year
he is going to look for
quarterbacks he loves quarterbacks uh
you know i think if he could if he could
have the best life you know what he
would do for 50 weeks a year he would be
the coach
and and
quasi personnel guy
you know of the raiders the other two
weeks a year you know what he'd do
john gruden's quarterback camp
he would have the top six or eight
quarterbacks every year
sit in that dank room in tampa with him
or now in vegas with him and he would
just grind for six or seven hours he'd
go out on the field and he'd watch him
throw he'd do all that
that is what gruden loves he is just
smitten with quarterbacks and so in my
opinion just my opinion
i think john gruden has a wandering eye
he's going to look at the quarterback
market this offseason if he thinks he
can do better he's going to try
and i will be shocked i've said it all
along if they don't make a play for tom
brady
chris sims has been one of those
quarterbacks on the roster while john
gruden's eye wanders toward others and
we've established recently that john
gruden is a quarterback hoarder
chris sims uses a term that has one
fewer syllable than that and i have
tried to convince him that the correct
term is hoarder
not that word without the dir
uh and uh it's a work in progress to say
the least to get sims to understand what
he means is hoarder not the other word
uh we've had some fun with that we
probably will this week in indianapolis
where
uh it's a perfect yeah
mike i'll tell you what you i'll tell
you what you have to do in indianapolis
this week
you gotta stake out gruden's press
conference and get him to come on the
set with chris sims
i want to see that i demand to see john
gruden and chris sims on set and by the
way mike
you go to the men's room while they're
on the air okay
i just want to hear from gruden and sims
how great would that be must see tv in
the florio household yeah as long as
you're not in there after having begun
your prep for a certain procedure i'll
go to the men's room for that segment
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports